I actually attended quite a few Pride
festivals and they were amazing but do I
agree that holding Pride festivals are a
good thing no I don't agree because
being gay I do believe is a sin and that
does something to the land like when we
celebrate that it can cause earthquake
diseases all these stuff to start to
happen according to the Bible we are
approaching the 150th episode of
middleground and we need your help to
continue making more episodes join our
middleground patreon and help us make
Middle
Ground
you're queer even if you suppress your
homosexual desires can the agre please
step
forward I think the idea of being xgay
is dishonest I think psychologically we
know sexuality though it can exist on a
spectrum is part of who we are it's an
innate part of who we are and I think
claiming X is claiming
that you've changed some part of you
that I don't think can be changed and I
think it's one thing to say I've chosen
not to lean into my desires it's another
thing to say I've been healed from or
completely eradicated those desires
within me yeah I agree while I want to
like honor and respect each person's
individual journey and their own
identity an orientation just can't be
changed um you can live it out in a
different way but it is uh how you were
created and psychologically speaking it
is damaging actually it leads to
depression and anxiety and obviously
like suicide or suicidal ideation that
the fruit of um trying to change
actually um is damaging to one's soul
and psyche can the disagre please step
forward the only identity I want to
claim over my life is child of God I
hate labels and so even as I came out of
the closet like like I I didn't like to
to announce myself as gay the only
identity that I clearly see with inside
of myself is being a child of God it's
what he has defined for me as a man why
is there conflict there between being a
child of God and and other parts of your
identity it's not really up to me to get
to Define like who I am and a lot of
times even in my own life like I thought
that I wanted certain things and then I
realized that those things were not good
for me so I based just my belief and my
identity on like what the word of God
says does that work in Reverse like what
if you want to be a singer or a painter
or something that is positive do you say
well I can't do that because I can't
find scriptural support that says I can
go be a painter like how do you feel
about that in the opposite like don't
you think that there are things God
instills inside of you to show you maybe
what his plan is for you and I'm with
you too my identity is in Christ but
there's so much that makes me me I'm
somebody's son I'm somebody's brother I
love Seline Deion and Taco Bell like
there's all these moving parts to make
Gilbert who Gilbert is and I just wonder
like where do you draw the line if you
think that you know God has to tell me
who I am well what if that's how I see
this God is always telling me who I am
yeah there are certain things inside of
us that they're they're not bad things
and so like if I wanted to be a singer I
did I did want to be a singer at one
point so I'm like oh that's awesome like
the Lord might want that for my life but
at the same time I also have to
surrender that to him and just tell him
okay like this is what I want to do but
you also get the last say because at the
end of the day like you formed in the
womb by him he knows you better than you
know yourself for myself as a Christian
as a believer in Jesus Christ I believe
in the power of Deliverance I believe
that you can be completely delivered
from homosexuality not only because of
what the Bible says but because of my
personal story you know I used to have
sex with men um I used to dress like a
woman um used to you know have a desire
to possibly be a transgender if it
wasn't for the grace of God but God
completely changed my desires you said
that your identity is in Christ but your
identity is also in the lgbtq I don't
know for do you identify as somebody in
the right so like I was saying there's
many things that make me mean when I say
that I'm gay it means that I'm being
honest about my attractions it's not
just like sexual it's also psychological
it's romantic it's all of these things
that I cannot have with a woman
sexuality is a choice everybody has the
the the the right of free will to choose
what they want to do but at the end of
the day our subjection to should be to
the word of God I can quote numerous
scriptures where it says that a man and
a man and a woman and a woman is
forbidden by God it doesn't mean that
God hates the person that is doing that
God loves everybody but he hates the sin
and it also says that those who approve
of such things or those who practice
such things will endure Hell Fire I
think I'm probably the most unique
person here because I firmly believe
first of all sexuality and gender are
not a choice and I say that as an
intersex person so I don't know if you
guys understand what being born intersex
means you might have heard the term
hermaphrodite I was born with a
condition called DEA Chapelle syndrome
um I'm chromosomally a female but there
was a gene mutation on my dad's Y
chromosome that caused me to develop
harshly male and then when I finally was
started to puberty I was actually
developing more like a female and I I
don't know I just think it's it's
disingenuous to say that like sexuality
or gender is a choice because I never
got the choice to be diagnosed with the
in sex condition that I have I think
that there's a lot of things we just
don't understand about sexuality and
gender so I come from a like a
scientific place I don't come from a
religious place so I'll say this I'll
agree that having samesex attraction is
not a choice in stuff because I had same
seex attraction since preschool and
stuff I didn't have that choice and
stuff I was like oh why am I attracted
to guys like how girls and guys nor we
are attracted to each other but I
definitely will say like you know as a
Christian from a theological standpoint
you do have a choice to act on it or not
and God gives us the power by the
strength of the Holy Spirit to have us
walk in a life that is Holy and pure and
righteous before him in Services what
always breaks my heart is that you have
pastors that are singing worship songs
like break my heart for what breaks
yours open up my eyes to the things
unseen and they are able to have this
palatable way of accepting LGBT people
by calling them same sex attracted but
then when we come into their church and
we're like but okay yeah if you want to
use that language but we're gay these
orientations don't they don't change but
like I said before what makes you be
able to Define yourself the definition
of the word I say it's that easy but who
gave you that authority to speak the
truth God no to to identify yourself I'm
using a definition of a word so to you
like you just can claim whatever
identity that you want for yourself no
unless it's true I had to come to the
realization that I was gay when I was
seeking a relationship with the Lord I
told the Lord I said hey this is how I
feel this is what I like but you're
going to have to show me that you're
real you're going to have to prove
yourself to me and he did and he took
those desires away from me he's given me
strength to overcome my desires of
falling into homosexuality again but
that doesn't mean temptation is not
there you know I don't get tempted as I
did before but even the Bible says Jesus
got tempted by the devil so like it's
not temptation is not a sin but I'm just
saying that the the Deliverance part
comes from the Holy Spirit giving me the
strength over that and completely there
religious component but the
psychological component is that then
you're repressing a part of your
sexuality it's not gone it's still there
but you're choosing to not engage why do
you call it repressing because there's a
lot of things that we do that what we
would consider something that I don't
want to do like let's say I love Big Mac
I love going to McDonald's I love eating
but that's not necessarily good for me
would you say that I repress my
need why does it have to be negative why
can't it be something positive yeah like
self control self self control is
repression so I think it's self control
say no but you all are you're saying
that this is necessarily negative I
think XG I want you to be honest and say
I still have the attraction and I'm
choosing to not engage with it rather
than telling people they can actually be
healed from their sexuality that's not
true there is scientific basis behind
being
lgbtq let's go
girl so I I feel like this prop is very
much about someone like me I think there
a scientific basis behind being born in
lgbtq community there is like so much
scientifical basis for someone like
myself and we've existed since the
beginning of time but the media never
platforms someone like myself like I
can't name one famous interex person and
I'm an interex person I think it's
mighty time that like we bring interex
voices forward because I think not only
can It help our community but it help
the trans Community with a lot of the
struggles of like people invalidating
their identity in like their manhood or
their Womanhood or they just their
personhood you know I think
psychologically scientifically we know
that homosexuality occurs throughout
nature this is not a question anymore um
and the idea welcome the idea this
language of unnatural which does
unfortunately come from the Bible is
just untrue scientifically we know that
homosexuality is a naturally occurring
phenomena in many species and in
humanity and so anybody who's trying to
claim that it's not an innate part of
human beings is not doing that from a
scientific standpoint I don't think any
animals are asking to be delivered from
their homosexuality like if we're going
to come from a religious standpoint as
someone who was religious for the first
13 years of my life the comment saying
God makes no mistakes I don't think God
made any mistakes and also about any of
just like my average uh transexual
brothers and sisters and non-binary
siblings like I don't think there's
anything inherently wrong with
that DNA cannot predict sexuality it
cannot predict if you're gay it cannot
predict if you're straight and also too
um with interex individuals we cannot
use the case of sexuals to generalize
the LGBT community but if someone can be
born like me why could someone not be
born homosexual bisexual transexual the
psychology is clear though there is not
a single Psychological Association in
the country that would say that
sexuality is something that can be
changed they would say it's an innate
reality and for gender as well because
it used to be like they did have
psychological terms homosexuality was
considered to be a disorder in the age
of Freud but we've moved on
since why have we moved on since that
was it the gay rights no Freud was
science Progressive as we get new
knowledge that's how science works I
believe if you if you were born with a
vagina you are a woman if you were born
with a with a with a penis you are a man
what about my you were in war and a
grenade went off and you lost your penis
what would your gender be still a man
okay but you don't have a penis you have
no genitalia yeah well that that's what
God gave me whatever God gave you with
it you can cut it off you can trap it on
whatever it is I believe that's still
what God God gave nonfunctioning
genitalia until I have reproductive like
I I want to ask a question that what
what are like if I don't want to be you
know no I'm I'm an open book so ask me
but reproductive organs like they don't
work like do you have a w so for me no I
was born with literally like almost no
internal sex organs and non fully
developed sex organs so when I was born
I basically had a uh partially formed uh
phus but I did not have testes did not
have ovaries I didn't have any inter
prostate anything like that and so when
I started going through puberty I never
got very masculate I never got like a
lot of facial hair but I did grow breast
tisue naturally so like what do you say
to someone like me who's like walking
around with breasts but you know I I
literally was never going to be able to
father or mother a child there's a lot
more to the conversation than just like
penis man vagina female XX This and like
I have XX chromosomes but like XX that
is male XX is uh female so I have
chromosomally a female however like my
condition is called deash Jael but it's
also known by some people as XX male
syndrome because like again people just
associate the penis being there as
something to be male but up to 50 % of
people with my condition do end up going
under some feminizing uh transition I'm
happy to share my story because I think
it's very important I think it would
help a lot of people understand that
like if I can be born this way why could
someone not be born a transperson why
could someone not be born a homosexual
or bisexual person well I want to
apologize for the Christian Community
because I think there has been a lack of
Education between gender and then also
sexuality I look at your case I'm like
man that's horrible that sucks like
attraction flesh full desires lust all
these types of things those are
different than gender as a believer in
the word of God I I believe that God
created a man and a woman so when it
comes down to in sex I don't believe God
is the author of confusion that's why I
don't believe if you have a little
breast tissue or you have some you're
not growing facial hair I can I I can
completely switch over to a female or I
can completely switch over to a male
because I have certain male or I'm a
woman and I have a beard I still feel
like what's between your legs what God
has created you God created man and
woman there's no I don't see any inner
sex I don't see any of
wow tremendously dismissive the very
first being that's been that was created
was genderless was
Adam let's just go with that that let's
just go with Adam and Eve are the first
okay but just because something is the
first it doesn't mean that it's the
standard if you look at Adam and Eve
then you're like oh that's what we have
to be they're the blueprint well then
that goes down to Slippery Slope because
then what was their hair color what was
their eye color what was their skin
color and any deviation from that means
that you're evil I'm also to a therapist
and I work with a lot of children who
have autism seeing families who you know
question like why was my child born this
way I kind of think of that scenario in
my head obviously you don't autism but
you being inex and coming out here I
think it's it's a wonderful thing
because you guys your stories are not
really heard I think of the scripture
when um a man went to Jesus about his
son who was born blind and he said why
was my um son born this way is it
generation yeah is it a result of my
sins and Jesus responded and said um so
the glory of God can be seen in him you
know that brings a lot of comfort to me
and when I think of a rare case of your
I know you don't you're not religious
you don't believe in that but that's how
I see you you know I see the glory of
God in you and I'm so glad you can see
the glory of God in part of the queer
Community my prayer is that you can see
it in all of the queer Community
conversion therapy has positive
outcomes praise the Lord yes thank God
nobody thank God nobody Ste forward I
guess can everybody come
forward
I believe converging therapy is
detrimental because I believe the only
person that can convert you is Jesus
Christ homosexuality is not the only sin
murdering is a sin thiefing is a sin if
I were to steal that jacket from you and
run out of here that's a sin you know
what I mean I don't believe converion
therapy is is is really converting
somebody because I believe homosexuality
is a demonic Spirit and the only way a
demonic Spirit can leave a person is
through the power of Jesus Christ so do
you hold homosexuality and murder on the
same level they're both s well can I say
something about conversion I actually
experienced uh conversion therapy so I
actually was an attendant of The Exodus
Ministries if you guys are familiar with
that that's what I'm sure was all going
to come up yeah it was devoted to
getting people to just have heterosexual
attractions and I remember we went up to
some mountain and there was protesters
outside of the hotel and I was forced to
go there by my parents but I don't think
that it worked just because Jesus wasn't
the center and so while I was there the
only thing that I learned was like this
is how you can be more masculine this is
how you can be more manly by playing
football and then the girls they would
teach them how to you know put on makeup
did you ever pray I don't know I'm
asking did I pray like the gay away well
yeah I know we all made those prayers of
course but I mean cuz I I never went
through that that that's not my journey
so I was wondering like in those
practices did they not incorporate like
did but it wasn't like the main goal
like I've been able to recognize Jesus
as the change of my desires to be able
to say my desires changeed to want to
submit my whole personhood to the
lordship of Jesus I don't feel it like
I'm like well I still have attractions
to men and I'm looking around the gym
and I'm like wow these guys are you know
goodlooking I'm so like I want to submit
my desires to the Lord and it that came
out of my desire to want to serve Jesus
not necessarily to want to be
heterosexual or to want to be more manly
I mean I spent years and years and years
doing exactly what you're talking about
fasting praying being prayed over
delivered all of the things that I was
told I needed to do to take away my
desire that I would submit to Jesus and
the time that I felt most filled with
the Holy Spirit was when I kissed a
woman um that is when I was filled with
peace and joy you know just like I want
to respect your stories there can't be a
disproving of the spirit of God in my
life that is a personal experience just
like you are having personal experiences
my personal experience and my community
and my family all bear witness to the
beautiful fruit of the spirit of God
being in my relationship with my wife
and our children can you link that fruit
back to the Bible because if you can't
link it back to the Bible
Corinthians just like God's Redemptive
order you know like if all the women in
the world decided to have sex with women
and all the men decided to have sex with
men there would no longer be any rep
reproduction God has created us straight
people who cannot reproduce of course
I'm just saying that there's an order to
the way way that God does things and so
if God produced me then like why
couldn't God produce like just a normal
gay person or just a normal transsexual
person like anything like that like I
just don't think that you can really
pray I I couldn't pray that away I have
a question about the word conversion
therapy because I did a year of
conversion therapy and that was meeting
with u ex lesbian person and we prayed
through my sins the idea behind
conversion therapy was that there was
trauma in my past and that was causing
my sexual orientation to skew and so I
spent a year doing all of this prayer
for deliverance and then I hear some
language here being talked about like
being delivered of homosexuality if it's
not being done by a clinical
psychologist that doesn't change the
fact that it's trying to convert you
from being one thing to another thing
and I think that is objectively harmful
it's not about bringing that Community
from gay to straight it's bringing them
from gay to a relationship with the Lord
I I I'm I'm married today I have a baby
on the way right um congratulations
thank you bro but I think when I tell
people my testimony they take the
highlight of my story as me being
married and me having a child on the way
but the highlight of my story is me
coming from a gay lifestyle to a
relationship with the Lord okay my my
desire to be with a man is no longer
there I want to be with a woman right
but it came from my relationship with
the Lord so it's about bringing that
Community from a relationship with the
Lord rather than from gist I've been a
therapist for almost 20 years and I
would say at least half if not more of
the clients that my team and I work with
are people just like you they call us
and they say I have three kids I have an
amazing life but in time time all it has
brought is suffering that is to be a
Christian is part of being suffering I
mean you should know this it's like
Jesus he denied himself he put himself
on the cross like there's probably going
to be suffered unnecessarily that's
right and why do we need to suffer as
people for a book that was written 3,000
years ago I'm sorry of the we have like
80 to 85 years on this planet I don't
want to suffer for anying reason that I
don't have to and I've had to suffer for
the first 24 years of my life the more
you suffer does it make you more of a
Christian it just and what did
Christians do before the Bible right
there thousands of years before there
was a text and even when the text came
most people couldn't read and they
didn't have access to the Bible so what
did they do I think it comes down to
like how you said your experience with
the holy spirit being filled up with the
Holy Spirit while kissing a female what
is the fruit that comes from out of that
we have children we have a beautiful
home we have a an amazing Community our
families love us and support us we are
happy and healthy I mean our life is so
so blessed but my thing about that would
be I would say that God cares more about
your Holiness than your happiness you're
defining heterosex your holess or
Holiness as heterosexuality well people
can have that no no oh I'm definitely
not def in the way that you're speaking
you're like it's not about being gay
Jesus wants me to be holy why are you
putting those two things against each
other gay people can live holy lives
exactly well I would say that I'm not
talking about like people who aren't
religious if you're not religious hey
you can live your life the way you want
to but if you do claim to be a follower
of Jesus God calls us to be set apart
and practicing homosexuality is a thing
he calls us to be set apart from and
that's just the true that's not in the
Bible that's not true true sorry you
can't lie like that about the Bible and
not have me say something a healthy
family requires a male and female role
model The Pride movement is negatively
affecting younger
Generations I experimented with by
uality when I was a teenager and I
didn't know what it was I didn't know
there was a label I just did it just
because I I felt good but it was until
College I realized like oh there's a
community LGBT so I was I was happy that
I found my identity in in the pride
community and I still do have family and
friends who I love who are in gay
marriages but after being born again
just the word itself it just didn't sit
right with me there's definitely agenda
an agenda behind it speaking spiritually
right I just think that we need to be
more aware aware of how we use that word
pride yeah no I for the pride like you
know speaking specifically about like
Pride parades and like um the entire
month of June celebrating Pride if it's
a thing that like people are inviting
children to and like people like you
know in Gin Z and things like that and
like you see like genitalia just like
out and like people just naked and stuff
like that I'm like that's not sending a
good message they're going to view at
view you guys as all sexual and all
lustful and stuff no self resect or
anything like that and like I I just
don't like personally a agree with that
um but then also they view disagreeing
with them about their lifestyle as being
homophobic when that's completely
different things and they're literally
training people like no if people
disagree with you about who you are
about the life that you live they're
homophobic they're scared of you they
want to be away from you and I do not
agree with that when I went to my first
Pride event I was 17 and I was like oh
people like me I get to be out here and
you know and while I was there looking
at the float there was a drag queen that
was performing she's Fierce and it was
all great but then there was this like a
go-go dancer right next to her and she
performed a sex act on him right there
in front of me and I was 17 and I was
one of the older people there were kids
and stuff and everybody was cheering and
celebrating and I just felt like this
wipe out from me like is this what that
is supposed to be but for me that was
way too much and in my line of work I do
work with kids and I'm hyper aware of
what they're exposed to I'm very
protective of kids when I was 8 years
old I was introduced to homosexuality um
through was know sure will pause drag
Grace that's what really in introduced
me to that right the Bible talks about
in Matthew chapter 6 how our eyes are
the lamp to our body and if we allow
Darkness into our eyes we allow Darkness
into our body all of those who are in
the lgbtq community but some are are are
pushing this demonic agenda on the kids
because kids minds are sponges and when
you show them that being a man and a man
and a woman and a woman being together
is okay they're going to grow up
thinking okay I can do the same thing
and when you do that you're you're
turning a whole nation into you know no
procreation none of these things is an
antichrist agenda especially in the
education now where they're teaching
kids about gay sex and and
transgenderism is okay and all that
stuff I feel like that thing is wrong
and I feel like it's a call to
repentance uh to turn back to the Lord
and and really just um um um um stop
that stuff when when when it comes down
to the kids to me I'm I'm conflicted
because I know that the gay rights
movement has done a lot of good like if
it wasn't for the gay rights movement
there would literally still be people
who are killed today just because they
face homosexuality you know what I'm
saying um is just that okay we can see
these individuals as equal and we don't
want to kill them anymore and um and
that's partly Christians Christians are
to blame like we we would kill like gay
people and trans people are still
murdered I have three personal friends
of mine who have been murdered for who
they are and so that's why I step
forward partially because I do think
sometimes there are um overly sexual
things that are may be done in front of
kids and like I say this as a drag
Entertainer I don't like to perform in
front of any kids because I'm I'm very
much like keep your kids at home because
also they're not even tipping me anyways
a lot of times they're loud they're
annoying they're spilling if I'm at a
drag Bunch they're spilling food
everywhere not my thing well I do think
it's important to teach kids about safe
sex and all types of sex whether it be
homosexual bisexual whatever type of sex
I think it's like an age thing to me
like I actually attended quite a few
Pride festivals and they were amazing I
Lov them I was so excited to be there
but that was because I identified and it
was the first place that I ever felt
truly welcomed and I think as Christians
we need to make more spaces where
lgbtqia they can come into the churches
and feel welcomed and feel safe but do I
agree that holding Pride festivals are a
good thing no I don't agree because once
again being gay I do believe is a sin
and that does something to the land like
when we celebrate that when we celebrate
these festivals it does bad things to
the land you know it can cause
earthquake diseases all these stuff to
start to happen according to the
Bible I think we need to separate the
idea of Pride and public acts of sex um
those are not the same thing but also
I'm a mom of nine-year-old Twins and um
we are the ones who put meanings on
things for our children bodies are not
bad so even if our kids see some um an
exposed body part we don't automatically
say that that's bad because it's not but
we do talk about how some people might
feel that that is negative and some
people might feel that is as positive I
think there's like biblical precedence
to that like God created us naked from
the very GetGo but then now once again
with the introduction of sin that's
where lust can creep its way in and so a
child that maybe saw a penis genitalia
something might happen there where if
had they not been exposed to that maybe
they would have remained a little bit
more innocent I definitely want my kids
to stay innocent you're right like I'm
not like look at this you know um that
to me that is that is absolutely harmful
but if we are in the world or even at a
pride festival which they love my kids
they feel so much of God's love in Pride
they are drawn to it um because they see
God's goodness and love reflected in it
and they see their moms who they love
reflected in it they have no definition
of bad in that that just kind of doesn't
sit well with me especially like the
fact that you're a Christian because
Pride cometh Before Destruction so I
just like cannot agree with that
statement and as a Christian maybe we
need to like relook at our Bible
that's pretty
offensive um and pretty judgmental The
Pride that's mentioned in the Bible is
different than the pride we're talking
about here and it's different than the
pride in a parade but we're talking
about is actually something that even
Christians uh I'm sure would identify
with and that is just like we are almost
mirrors of God's uh diversity and
inclusion and uh love that like it's
like this light coming down and hitting
me and reflecting off and that enjoyment
when we reflect God's creation and
goodness and love that is so it's
enjoyable and so that's really what
pride is about these stories though are
far and few between I've been to
probably 15 parades and festivals over
the past 10 years at any Festival where
there's going to be drunken people like
this is Marty gr as well like this is
anywhere media focuses on too so
uplifting these one stories and say look
there was a penis exposed at this pride
parade this is all what pride is about
that's what happens in the media that's
what furthers LGBT oppression because
we're demonizing us as some sexual
deviants that are trying to groom
children that's not what anybody why way
more scared that we're going to be
harmed at those than my kids are going
to see a penis I I'm to I'm 1,00%
against whether it's Christians or just
Norm people who are not religious who
bash the lgbtq community killing I'm not
for that I don't stand with that though
I believe that it's a sin live however
you want to live just don't push it on
the children would you say the same
about Christianity don't push Christian
on the children no well that's the thing
is that there was there was an influence
I remember back in the day it was a
campaign that was called um it gets
better I had did not have a good
childhood growing up especially with all
these attractions living in Miami very
maeso culture and looking at the TV and
being like well it's going to get better
for me like eventually like I'm going to
be happy but it was that influence that
kept me going to want to be gay to think
like oh my life is going to get better
if I just give into this and I am very
thankful for the people on this panel as
well for us pioneering a new movement
the Hol movement where we telling
children hey if you have these
attractions that's okay understand these
attractions what do they mean let's not
throw it out the window but I don't want
another make it uh they're deal with
they're not dealing with the attraction
they're they're dealing with wanting to
be accepted for their attraction that's
the difference gets better actually it
gets better because it's incredibly
painful to live in a community like you
described and I can only imagine the
amount of pain that you experienced I
would love to transport you to a
different place a different home a
different family and to see if your
experience was would be the same I think
they wouldn't lgbtq people won't go to
heaven I want to make the distinction
between people who have same seex
attractions and people who are actively
living according to those same seex
attractions because the Bible says in 1
Corinthians 6 that if you're practicing
homosexuality you will not inherit the
kingdom of God as as so as a drunker as
show as so as a reviler the New
Testament alone has enough evidence that
the lifestyle of homosexuality is sinful
and against God and we can't say that
we're followers of Jesus but yet live
according to our flesh we can't say that
we're filled with the Holy Spirit but
yet do what we want to do you mentioned
First Corinthians 6 chapter 9 U chapter
6 verse 9-10 where it talks about
neither the homosexual neither the
drunker neither the the thief will enter
the kingdom of heaven but we forget the
verse after that but such were some of
you but you were washed by the blood of
the Lamb that's scripture to prove that
there is deliverance from any demonic
Spirit including homosexuality and those
who uh practice such things or those who
even approve or support such things will
go to hell that's why I I disagree with
those who call themselves gay Christians
you cannot claim something Divine and
demonic at the same time if you're gay
and you're like I don't want God God is
not going to force you God is a
gentleman and I think that's the saddest
thing is that most people they've been
told oh gays are going to go to hell
just automatically and that's not true
that's not true at all you know it's a
process of sanctification that's what we
read about in the word that it's like
it's present it's future and it's past
tense and
sanctification I just want to say and
I'm you guys are putting yourself in the
spot you all stepped forward on this
knowing that she was in the room that
literally is saying that you believe
that she should go to hell for something
that you have even literally confessed
that you realize it's a biological
scientific thing thing her DNA says that
she's a female and since she's a female
she's living she's LGBT well that's
something completely different gender
from attraction is different The Prompt
was LGBT people it wasn't people who are
engaging in sexual conduct whether
you're straight it just says LGBT people
and you all stepped forward don't give
me this whole thing about well if you're
practicing that wasn't the prompt y'all
came forward y'all stepped out and said
that she was going to hell I did because
I don't believe she was born a woman
that for you to decide you don't have
the authority do that listen I I love I
I I I this this is my friend I I I I I
have love for this person this is how
you treat your friends yes I tell them
the truth because I want them to go to
you don't know the truth you more know
more about truth about her than she does
brother the truth is in the word of God
but let me let me let me explain my oh
my L to Georgia are you paying attention
to anybody's words that don't agree with
you she was born with a pen she
explained her story not a fully
developed penis not a fully developed
penis I wasn't born with testes I wasn't
born with a prostate I was
I just want to say at the end of the day
God looks at our heart if you ever
decide to become a Christian um I'm just
saying like he doesn't look at our
appearance he looks at what's in our
heart the second that you all stepped
forward I honestly started to get a
little bit teary eyed because I was
thinking the millions of people that
that might see this and the the what it
says is it goes to how you view God that
you are scared of God God's love is ever
expanding the Gates of Heaven are wide
and God welcomes all of us in and so it
says that your view of yourselves and of
God in the world is a scary place and
it's just not and that if you can claim
sir that I can't be gay and Christian
that actually can't happen because to be
a Christian the definition is for me to
have a relationship with the Divine
you're not inside of me so you cannot
prove or disprove that just like I can't
prove or disprove your experiences or
your relationship with God I am a gay
Christian and I have the spirit of God
inside of me there's no scripture that
you can point to that can disprove that
because it's about my personal
relationship with my soul and heart with
the Divine being we call God I actually
do I have a SC I have two scriptures I
just told you you cannot use scripture
sir but that's but but but we're
Christians if you're going to hold the
Bible above my personal relationship
with Jesus Christ then you have held the
Bible as an idol what Bible do you read
I'm just curious the same one uh the
Holy Bible I actually feel like a better
question is what Bible do you read what
translation because right okay so
there's a documentary out now brand new
got bubble w right on it it's called
1946 the movie you can disprove it yes I
can because we have the original Greek
manuscript he knows all about arsi does
not mean homosexuality maybe you can
watch the documentary and you can go
into Yale University and you can go
through the vaults and you can see what
the Bible translators decided on which
was released in 1946 and have your own
opinion but ultimately you just cannot
deny that the fact that the word
homosexual is a combination of Maloy and
Areno cotai put together I would even
say forced together it was challenged by
David Shelton who wrote the letter to uh
was Luther wiel who was a head of the
Elder diversity and he admitted he said
you know what you're right this is a bad
translation and see I think the
arrogance in the conversation that is
off-putting to those of us who are
openly LGBT is that by saying you know
that people are going to hell you have
placed yourself in the place of God and
said you know the hearts you know how
God is going to judge and that I think
is anatha I think that's an unchristian
unbiblical stance to take would you say
that it would be wrong for us to tell a
drunker like he spends the rest of his
life being a drunker would you say it
would be wrong for us to say hey the
Bible says you would not inherit the
kingdom of God I don't think drunkenness
sends anyone to hell I think it is by
Grace we are saved through faith not of
ourself he has a different theology than
what we have and that's the that's the
the real issue is that he believes in
all Grace so everything not all Grace
don't put words in my mouth I believe
that God will ultimately redeem every
everyone every knee will bow every
tongue will you believe in Repentance
literally not what theit people will
spend in eternity separate from God
because of their sin do you believe in
Repentance do you believe that
repentance necessary but not repentance
from homosexuality because homosexuality
is not a sin biblically it's healthy to
experiment with
sexuality you know like I have
experimented with women and men and I
found myself attracted to both I would
say more to men so like like a 75 25 I
guess I would say it was a very a
fulfilling experience to know who I was
and why I was feeling these attractions
and if these attractions were like valid
like or they were like really grounded
and like how I was really feeling in
stuff like that for a lot of people I
believe that they are very much on the
straight end of the spectrum or the gay
end of the spectrum talking sexuality
wise for a lot of people there is
ambiguity in between and in our
increasingly open and inclusive world
there is now space for people to say
well if I'm not on those polls then
maybe I need to figure out myself and I
think my greatest harm and Trauma in
life came from being a part of a church
who when I started to realize that I
didn't align with heterosexuality in the
way that I was taught I needed to said
there is no experimentation there is one
way for you to be you have to be
straight and in order to be straight you
should go to conversion therapy XYZ
that's very objectively harmful it CS me
objective harm and I think it's such a
great thing now that we live in an era
where we can tell kids and youth as
they're coming into puberty there's not
a mold for you to fit into you are
created beloved unique figure it out
figure out what works for you and it's
okay I mean it's healthy to try things
out while simultaneously being deeply
connected to yourself and listening to
your soul and your heart and the Divine
that is within you that's how we learn
as people that's how we were created to
learn is to try things out now if you're
going over a boundary of someone else or
an internal boundary that you have and
you're not and you're shutting that down
that's where harm comes when you start
to harm yourself or harm someone else
but if there's a consent happening how
beautiful that you could be listening to
yourself and honoring yourself and
honoring someone else while learning
about yourself exactly absolutely I tend
to be kind of like what you were saying
Brandon more on the very gay
side uh when I was young I kissed a girl
and I didn't like it for me it was like
I didn't necessarily want that
experience but I guess it kind of
confirmed that it's not not for me I
feel like there are a lot of people who
are kind of still figuring it out
there's a lot of people where it's not
as clear for them as it is for me
whether you're gay or straight or even
if you're like hey you know I'm kind of
trying to figure this out I'm not really
comfortable with being sexual there's so
much more to intimacy than just the
sexual act but if I'm a gay man I'm not
going to be complimentary to a straight
woman that's not going to be a a
relationship that's going to complement
each other I don't think that I
necessarily need to engage in that and
marry her and then take over that spot
of her life that could be going to a
straight man I think if you are marrying
someone outside of your orientation that
is absolutely one of the self most
selfish things that you can do it's
important to say that in this question
like SE exploring sexuality does not
mean having sex it means exploring who
you are and how you're attracted and how
you show up in the
world
lgbtq I A Plus what's in plus more
experimentation more if you want to do
this whatever you want to do if you want
to have sex with a dog have sex with a
dog if you want to have sex with a if
you want Bo if you're a boy you want to
have sex with a boy have sex with a boy
if you're a woman you can have sex with
a woman all this stuff it's leading to
that though so when you tell a nation
and you tell a society to fulfill the
lust of the flesh which is what it is is
you're telling them oh just just do
whatever you want whatever you feel
these things and that's why no harm in
homosexual sex there is harm in sex
committed with a child with an animal
and that is completely wrong I will
never support that as a person in this
community and that is very important to
say that anybody who tries to attach to
that part of the community I don't want
anything to do with that so your
understanding maybe it's your experience
and I feel really sad if that's been
your experience that is not what it
means to be lgbtq plus I I have a I feel
like I have a little bit more of a heart
when when it comes to homosexuals and
and everyone struggling in there like I
I faced so much struggle in my life I
was bullied all throughout my childhood
and I was suicidal at one point and so
it was rough and and that has also
helped me to understand that I think
it's okay to like recognize the emotions
and the feelings that you are having and
to to make room at the table for that
like the last thing that I would want is
for someone to not be able to talk about
the attraction that they're feeling in
church or to feel like judged or to feel
condemned or to feel hatred from someone
or even to be killed for just speaking
up and that still happens today and
that's that's what makes me sad okay so
I've heard multiple of you guys say like
about creating a safe space for lgbtq
people in a church right to talk about
certain things what do you say to
someone like me who has experienced
sexual assault and witnessed sexual
assault in a church I think that's
horrible yeah and I've been sexually
assaulted twice once before I was
Christian and another time when I was a
Christian and so I would say to you that
I sympathize with you and that it's
horrible and that was not God's will
that was not within God's plan that's
evil and whoever did that should be
punished according to the word of God
but the problem is is that the Catholic
Church in particular does not the person
who did that to me and to other which
just move parishes and it's a sh don't
talk about it yeah and we would 100%
disagree with that like for me
personally like I come against like the
the church a lot and a lot of the sinful
practices that it has done in the past
and stuff when it comes to essay and
when it comes to like covering things
cuz I mean when I first came out as gay
and stuff like that um and I went to
Baptist Church there a while but I
wanted to talk about how it was feeling
and they were just like no just just go
be with a woman just just go go sleep
around with a woman and then you'll be
fine I'm like what are you serious like
what that's so horrible we're social
media influencers and I I rarely ever
get seen like our testimony be put on a
stage in the Christian churches
Pentecostal Baptist like I've had a
YouTube channel for 5 years it has over
like 500 uh thousand views and rarely
ever do I get a call from the church
being like hey come share your testimony
come speak on this so I went to Catholic
High School and my freshman year of high
school we had somebody come and speak go
wow why homosexuality and the time
trends V ism is the word they use I hate
the word transvesti but they use that
word why that was sinful and why that
was wrong to our entire school okay so I
actually grew up a Catholic and I don't
agree with a lot of their Doctrine you
need to be born again to to know the
word of God I think you know
experimenting with my sexuality was not
healthy for me I didn't even realize
what I was doing at the time the
inclination came to me from a young age
and then you know throughout my
teenagers I'm like H I like boys I like
girls let me try this but later in my
years I dealt with so much anxiety I
dealt with um a little bit of depression
because of like the stress of going to
school and when I went through my
Deliverance I didn't go into my
Deliverance being like Oh I need to be
delivered from being a bisexual I went
into my Deliverance wanting to be set
free from anxiety and and doubt and you
know all those things and so you know
answering the prompt it's I don't think
it's healthy I would agree with the
promp and disagree with the prompt at
the same time agreeing in a sense of
like if you're not religious at all
stuff like that I think you have free
relationship do do that experiment and
do all these things and stuff like that
and find out like who you think you are
and stuff like that and experiment in
that way but I do say if you are
claiming to be a follower of Jesus or
like in in the context of like
Christianity and stuff like I do say
that like the Bible would come against
like you trying to like you know go out
there and like have like your
experiences and do this and experiment
with that one God's like no no no like
no no experimenting here like you're
called to follow the scriptures you're
called to be led by my Holy Spirit and
to submit to me ultimately and Stu stuff
and whatever that looks like for you
that's if we're calling ourselves
followers of Jesus Jesus should be the
standard of who we are following and who
we should submit Our Lives to yeah I
think one of my first experiences um I
lost my virginity through an app called
grinder and so I was led to experiment
on grinder and I opened up doors that I
wish I would have never opened up before
and that's why I'm like no don't
experiment like if you're having the
attractions like understand the
attractions but don't go out there
because now I struggle a lot with sex
addiction I struggle a lot with tempt
there's some that you can't unsee and
that you can't undo once you've opened
that door yeah so when people struggle
with the things that you've mentioned
it's usually because they've repressed
it right and that there hasn't been like
a healthy way to express that and
experience it as you've been created
which makes it worse can I can I want to
ask the panel something it seems that
this whole conversation is going in the
way of experimenting with the same sex
do you feel that way also with the
opposite sex like let's say I was
someone who was like hey I'm gay I don't
want to be so maybe I should try to go
and date a girl I would say no because
to me it's not about once again getting
into a relationship with a female it's
about Holiness it's about experimenting
in Jesus it's it goes for the same Sexes
there shouldn't really be a difference
and that's why I'm like man I hope we
don't have division because it's the
same heterosexual homosexual even though
for the homosexuals it's been far far
worse but now let's not do that let's
forgive let's move in progress I think
we found some middle ground on this
issue because I do appreciate what you
just said I really do because even
though we may fundamentally disagree
about you know the whole affirming
somebody's uh samesex orientation I
really do feel a little bit encouraged
that it's not your guys' stance to go
push somebody into a heterosexual
relationship because I do feel like
that's often what the church tries to do
kind of like what you were told you know
what I mean like just go date a girl you
know all the time that we're were
talking I kept thinking about Jesus
healing somebody on the Sabbath and how
controversial that was because that was
a loving thing to do and all of the
religious people of the day were like
clearly you are breaking the law by
healing somebody and it wasn't just
something he did once he was a habitual
healer he did it all the time the law is
for love and we get sometimes so weirded
out by how are we supposed to love each
other that we forget that it's really
just treating your neighbor as yourself
do unto others as you would have them do
un to you it's supposed to be so so easy
I just want to implore all of us to
honesty and I don't think it's honest to
claim to be xgay because not one of you
have said that you have actually been
delivered of your sexuality and by
promoting that message you are causing
unnameable harm to young people in
churches who are going to think that if
they pray or go to therapy or follow
your version of Christianity that God is
going to take away their sexual
orientation and their sexual desire
I've not heard that said here I've heard
I've chosen not to do this I've chosen
to turn away say that but don't promote
this message that you can be or should
be healed of the way that God created
you thank you you can thank each other
and you
God
yeah